if you work in real estate you're a
small business owner you're a financial
service provider and you ultimately want
to generate more leads and sales buckle
your seatbelt for this entire
grow with video live show because
there's going to be some powerful tips
you're going to want to apply to growing
your business today i am joined by levi
lasik and his business partner travis
plum we're talking about how to double
your real estate business with a simple
youtube strategy he's gonna be revealing
some really powerful
tips on how together they did over 165
transactions in real estate just from
youtube organic traffic which was 90
million dollars in volume uh which led
to 2.7 million dollars in real estate
commissions that's just the tip of the
iceberg of their business empire that
they're building um and it's really
going to be some incredible tips that
you can apply to your channel so buckle
your seatbelt this is the growth video
live show and we're getting into it
right now
[Music]
what is up sean cannell here helping you
grow your influence on youtube and i'm
so fired up for this show today because
we're going to be learning all about how
to grow your business
with
youtube and so a lot of creators out
there we're trying to do adsense which
is great affiliate marketing which is
super cool but if you're a business
owner you're a real estate agent you
maybe haven't even understood the
potential power of leveraging youtube to
get more leads more clients more inbound
traffic and so i'm super fired up and i
want to welcome first today with me uh
levi lasik now um if you haven't met him
yet he has a channel called living in
dallas uh he'll break down some of the
details there but they've been crushing
it with all kinds of results
on the channel uh he's based out of
dallas texas today i think he's coming
to us from somewhere else in the world
he's got a property in belize he's an
iraq combat combat veteran thank you
levi for your service and he's lived all
over the place and so let's welcome levi
to the show today levi how's it going
hey sean it's going great thank you so
much for having us
um yeah super fired up and i also want
to welcome travis plum to the show this
is uh levi's business partner and uh
travis how's it going what's up sean
thanks for having us man it's going
great
fired up to be here now i want to hear
your story in just a second but before
we get even into that can you just levi
pitch me the high level vision of what
you guys are doing on youtube and kind
of break it down
yeah absolutely so i really started with
uh you know picking up a copy of youtube
secrets and uh and what happened was is
that i was making a transition i had a
business go to zero that i'd been
building for the last five years during
2020 when everything shut down and so i
knew i needed to make a transition and i
have very successful friends in real
estate but i never really wanted to be a
real estate agent because i know all the
hard work they go through in the first
two three four five years of their
business you know cold calling door
knocking shaking hands kissing babies
just trying to generate business that's
the reason why most agents or even
business owners go out of business
within the first two years is because
they don't or they're unable to generate
enough business or lead generation so i
knew i needed a good marketing plan i
had a mentor michael reese who said it's
not the best real estate agent that wins
it's the best marketer so coming into it
i wanted to take the approach from a
marketing standpoint and a business
owner standpoint not a one-on-one real
estate
agent who just you know shakes hands and
tries to to generate business that way
so as i was researching the platform i
always start with books and so you know
youtube secrets was there and i read
that and really benji just had one
paragraph in the back end of that that
mentioned about you know talking about
real estate and providing value on a
channel and he did this in 2009 and so
that's what really kind of sparked down
the road to where i thought you know
what i wasn't really interested in the
other platforms i researched them i
researched them but none of them really
set well with my gut i know that a lot
of agents and business owners were
gaining a lot of followers on tick tock
or instagram but whenever i really dug
in i didn't see a lot of business that
was being generated from that not that
you can't and i know several that are
very successful on those platforms but
it just didn't seem like a good fit for
me so youtube as i started to dig into
it and look into it as a strategy i
found that you know it's a search engine
it's not really a social media platform
and so therefore if people are
intentional and they're searching i
think it's a lot easier to get found on
youtube than any other platform because
you know if you can
figure out someone's intention then you
can likely grab their attention and so
that way uh you know we were able to
produce videos and with the tools out
there you know similar uh you know their
softwares and things like that that help
you understand what people are searching
for which goes into why we name the
channel living in dallas texas is
because i knew starting out
you know we had no brand i had no name
nobody's searching levi lassic on
youtube so it was okay well millions of
people are searching dallas texas every
single month and so you know it was just
a matter of finding what people are
searching for and creating content
towards that and that's really what
started the path as far as uh you know
trying to provide value up front and
then gaining the business on the back
end
man so inspiring and uh in just a second
we're going to get into some specific
tips that real estate agents can use and
of course even business owners regarding
the mindset of approaching youtube some
tools the activities that you do daily
what gear do you need to get started and
even just time management because i know
business owners are busy
um but before we get into that can you
just break down sort of the journey and
uh travis uh can maybe uh shine some
light on you know when did you guys
start the channel
and and what were the actions and kind
of the timeline of today
over 90 million
uh dollars in volume in real estate
transactions uh just crazy and and is it
accurate to say you haven't been doing
paid facebook ads
are you guys advertising on zillow and
getting zillow to give you leads for 125
each or you know or more you're not
doing any of that stuff but you're
investing in youtube and it definitely
takes time and you've even hired people
and stuff to help you as it's gone on
but the roi is freaking mind-blowing so
so break down just the journey of when
you posted the first video to today
well if i can i'll let travis um talk
about the transactional side but the
start of it was
whenever i started to move into
youtube i understood that you need to
understand
the the platform from a producer side
versus a consumer side so i'm 42 years
old and if i believe if you're like 40
years old and above that we have this
love hate relationship with social media
right we think it's silly because all we
see is people posting uh lunch their
lunch and cat videos but the reality is
is that person posting cat videos is
probably making a million dollars on the
other side right because they understand
the platform from a producer versus a
consumer so i took time those two months
once you know uh to study the platform
so a book like youtube secrets like
think media's channel you know that's
where i started to really dig in and
spend almost two months researching
youtube as a platform first to
understand the back end and how it
worked then i started to develop a plan
how could that work towards real estate
and literally wrote out a business plan
about everything that i wanted to
accomplish and work towards over the
next several months because i understood
in my research that consistency was key
in the beginning and so therefore i
couldn't just upload a video just to
upload a video because i think that's
where not only agents but most business
owners or anybody that gets onto youtube
makes a mistake is that they they
they film one or two videos they get all
excited they publish it and then they
don't have a plan for much after that so
i don't believe in analysis paralysis
but i do believe that it does help if
you understand and have a plan for the
next couple of months at least worth of
content ideas what are you going to film
so whenever i sat down and actually
wrote out a business plan then that's
what allowed me to really get started
and and have a clear vision of where we
wanted it to go we didn't understand how
it would grow so quickly or anything
like that but you know that's about the
time whenever we started publishing we
published the first video on december
5th 2020 so really about 15 months ago
15 16 months ago and just started to
create that content and this was all i
focused on just brand new licensed real
estate agent didn't try to door knock
cold call didn't bug my friends or
families to see if they wanted to sell a
house just focus completely on youtube i
just had this belief factor that if i go
all in on one platform one source one
marketing system you know could i master
that first and then maybe branch off but
that's you know about the time as i got
um you know i initially had met travis
earlier when i started the channel but
we didn't partner together in the
beginning but as i started to build up
more and more content and videos you
know we started to um you know get to
know each other a lot better and then
you know i was looking to really come at
this from the marketing standpoint i
wanted to be the content creator i
wasn't really looking to become a real
estate agent as far as opening doors and
showing homes so when i met travis
that's where he came in and he was one
of the first things he said to me was
hey i want to sell 100 homes and i
thought well this sounds like a good fit
because if he wants to sell 100 homes
and i want to make videos
and then this could this could work out
so that's where we started to work
together
right around the time that the first the
first lead started to come in and i was
able to pass those on to travis he was
able to take charge of that and then and
then travis took over from there and i
tell you what he came from the car
business he was newly licensed as well
and and got licensed december 5th
or december 2020 so he was just starting
out never sold a home neither one of us
didn't sell a home in 2020 didn't sell a
home in the first quarter of 2021 and
then here comes travis with his
amazing sales skills and i tell you what
it would you know i would let him take
over from there
yeah that's powerful because then to
break it down you start thinking okay
youtube you start thinking about traffic
and you start basically kind of the
three-step process is like get views on
youtube yep second capture a lead
and then three follow up and so this is
where travis comes in now what are you
doing to follow up as someone interested
in buying or selling a home comes in so
travis take it away talk about the
transactional side and how youtube works
together with what you were doing yeah i
mean i really appreciate that yeah i
mean the the dynamic that levi and i
have uh i call them the ying to my yang
all the time because we're able to kind
of you know conquer and divide because
at the very beginning you know i was
shooting uh on the fort worth side you
know i wanted to get into youtube i
wanted to do the video content but
slowly but surely we really started
seeing you know these leads pouring in
and i've been in sales since 2010 like
that that's what i do
and then previously to getting into real
estate i own my own digital marketing
agency you know i've i've spent you know
millions of dollars on facebook ads and
google not me personally but of other
people's money running their campaigns
and i mean we had full-blown call
centers text automations email
automations we had all these different
lead capture things that we actually had
to have in order to convert leads and
facebook instagram google they're only
converting at about
you know one to three percent maybe five
percent if you're really really really
good whereas we're converting in about
15 16 17 on youtube so the the quality
of the lead that's coming in is much
more serious the conversion time is much
shorter so with my my background and all
this marketing stuff you know i was i
felt really confident you know and in
sales that i could take these leads from
the start to the finish and just slowly
but surely i mean last year our first
deal actually closed in april i think we
only closed one or two deals last april
and so since last april really just in
one year we've done over 90 million
dollars in transactions and that's
because we have built out really good
systems and processes to follow up with
the clients um after the fact i mean
the number one thing about youtube is
the quality of the client is far
superior to anything that i've ever seen
in my you know 12 13 years of being in
sales better than facebook better better
than anything so these people are very
very serious so you have to take that
serious and then i mean it was like i
mean it was literally going from nothing
to going to everything in a very short
amount of time so you know when levi
took the first probably 300 phone calls
and you know people were you know super
excited to talk to him so there was a
little hesitation about me taking those
initial phone calls but when we made
that switch it was like we never even
missed the beat because levi we always
talk about our team right so the leads
were coming in they were coming in and
then it was like okay well now i'm
selling you know five six seven eight
deals a month now i'm getting really
really busy
and leads were starting to
you know they needed to be more followed
up with right so once i started doing
about eight transactions a month that's
when i was like levi we got to build a
little bit more so we started working on
the crm we started working on a little
bit more automation like everything that
we have is completely automated so like
when a lead comes in and they book their
call all we do is we take that card and
we slide it to property alert search
right that way they all the triggers
fire off they know that they're getting
their property search then i built out a
coming into town because our clients
they're all relocation and i can touch
on why i believe relocation is the best
buyers that you could ever have but when
we slide them into coming into town that
automatically lets them fill out a
calendar that you know whenever they're
coming into town it automatically goes
onto my calendar or someone on my team
and as they get closer into coming into
town they're getting a text message hey
you're only three weeks out for me in
the town we're so excited is there
anything we can do for you then two
weeks out then one week out then three
days out you know if we send them to a
lender there's automations built into
the lender we want to make sure that our
traffic that's coming in is taken care
of and that they're following the
process that we put into place all the
way from start to finish which is why
you know we're able to sell so much real
estate so quickly just because the
quality is there and you know everyone
who's relocating during a really short
period of time frame store average
conversion which anyone who's run
facebook or google knows conversions are
you know four months to nine months
right if you're really good youtube or
average conversion is 45 days and the
only reason it's 45 days is typically
because the clients aren't coming in for
two or three or four weeks and when they
come in they're pre-approved we know who
they are they love us they're ready
there's no competition and boom we're
able to get them under contract very
very quickly
long story short yeah i mean drop in
serious bombs too just about the power
and i think anybody listening to this
especially as a business owner is uh
is like wants to know more and in just a
second we're going to talk about even
everything down to like what kind of
tools uh levi are you filming with uh as
you're doing neighborhood tour tour
tours and some tips for getting started
with this but before we get into
everything else today's
growth video live show is brought to you
by
grow a video live um what a surprise
right and i want to let you know early
bird pricing for grow a video live is
actually ending soon in just a few days
prices are going up and you can even
save off of early bird pricing which is
happening right now
with the coupon code gwvl show
and use that at
growethvideolive.com the url is on the
screen right now the coupon code is on
the screen right now and that's going to
get you an additional five percent off
tickets now levi and travis are actually
joining us in vegas to be a part of the
event first and foremost but also as
guest experts so if you can imagine
getting to network talk with and connect
with uh high level leaders business
owners real estate agents content
creators influencers that's really
what's going to be happening at growth
video live and so i'm super excited
check out this quick video and then
we're going to be back with some more
tips this thing is your gateway to get
out of the thing that you complain about
but people would rather complain about
how it is than put in the work we need
to start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room you will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
[Music]
here golden era of not only business but
life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
[Music]
grow a video live 2022 is just a few
weeks away and if you want to join gary
vaynerchuk patrick bett david jasmine
starr chalene johnson alex hermosie
aaron on demand vanessa lau anthony
o'neill omar l tacory heather taurus
levi lasik travis plum uh you gotta come
to uh go to growthvideolive.com now
really quick there's a couple different
ticket levels and we've been getting
questions about this you can attend in
person there's a general admission level
there's a vip level but there's also
what's called the platinum experience
now if you can't come to vegas you can
also attend online and there's also
what's called the all access online
experience and to simplify it
you can go to glo
gwvl
platinum.com for the details and people
been wondering like wait a minute is
this a three-day event or a two-day
event and growth video live is a two-day
event it's a monday and a tuesday
towards the end of may but there
actually is a third day which is our
business mastermind day so if you would
actually say
like i'm a little bit further along in
my business i already have some momentum
and i want to network with high level
leaders i would love red carpet
treatment the entire time you know
reserve seating up front
i would love some of those things but
also an entire extra day that's who this
is for and actually we have on platinum
day uh if you want to get my personal
attention heather taurus the think media
team we have a special fireside chat
happening with alex and layla hermosie
uh this is gonna be a real high level
day where business minds are speaking
about how they growth hacked and scaled
their businesses growing to seven
multiple eight figures
and of course it's at the beautiful m
hotel and resort in las vegas this is
off strip it's about 10 minutes off the
las vegas strip platinum day includes
photos you can get a personal photo with
gary vaynerchuk and patrick bet david
which are keynoting the first two nights
of the conference
but you'll also be able to
network and connect with people like
travis plum and levi because we're going
to be in a much smaller group and really
just working on next level strategies
for our businesses and so again you
could join at any level and take
advantage of the discount code
but if you uh if this sounds like
something that you would be into you'd
say i really want to invest my in my
business at the next level just use the
coupon code and you can go to
gwvlplatinum.com
again all the links are in the
description or in the chat as well and
there's all kinds of different levels we
made this conference available for you
whether you want to attend virtually
whether you want to be in person whether
you want to go to another level and have
meals included and things like that and
all of the details
are in the description as well and make
sure because you're a watcher of the
grow with video live show
you get a special coupon code that we
only share here well i want to bring
levi back on and i want to talk a little
bit about mindset strategy tips for
getting started at with some of these
things
but i'm curious what camera setup you're
using and your team is using when you
have these nice
uh gimbal shots here as you're doing
these neighborhood tours levi break down
just some of the tools you're using
that is an iphone 11 pro on a 20
uh adjustable tripod
i love it that's it and then no no
microphone or anything uh yeah no i use
a shure mv
it's a little plug-in it's like a
plug-in boom mic on that plugs directly
into the iphone so you don't need any
batteries and it's directional so it
pretty much cuts off everything behind
you and just really captures your voice
but you have to be careful if you're a
feet dragger it will actually pick up
you dragging your feet on the concrete
so it's is the mv 88 plus or the no no
no yeah that one right yeah it's good
right here yep it's that's it's that
small a direct plug into the iphone and
that that's it that's the wow that's
really the most exp well if you don't
count the iphone that's the most
expensive piece of equipment but
otherwise i use a 20 ulanzi uh little
tripod one of those adjustable tripods
that has the three legs because it's
about a foot long and that just gives me
a little extra extension but the iphones
have built-in stabilization so you don't
need a gimbal gimbals are very heavy and
and clunky to work with in my opinion
and so all of these and as you can see
we feature different team members on
here which we modeled this after the
think media uh channel because this is
something that i
saw us moving into later down the road
how i love how on think media you know
you have multiple creators doing one
video a week but then you're still
putting out three four or five pieces of
content each week but it's not
overbearing on the on the team members i
in my opinion and so that's something we
wanted to incorporate because
we wanted to brand dallas we wanted to
brand the team we wanted to
show that it i don't have to be the face
all the time on this which is very
important as well because we believe
this is what's going to help the channel
be more sustainable over time and also
helps clients become familiar with our
team members so that we act they
actually get direct reach outs as well
people love their videos if they do
something solo and they'll directly ask
for you know aj or a couple of the other
different team members that have created
videos so it's very powerful for them
too because like aj was a brand new
agent on our team he's pacing almost 200
000 in commissions himself in his first
year in real estate and he's able to
make videos with our audience and so
people directly reach out just to work
with aj which is very powerful for him
as a brand new agent to already have
eight deals or so under contract or
closed within the first four months it's
a very good pace he's pacing uh very
well for himself and and he's also
developing his own name within the
channel
man i love it and i actually want to ask
travis a question i noticed this is
pretty cool uh larry
lelander is here and actually says i can
attest for travis plum i've known him
for five years he knows his stuff when
it comes to sales and marketing
congratulations to you and levi on your
success
super cool to see that by the way smash
like if you've been getting value out of
today's content and i would love to know
where you're watching from live or on
the replay
but travis can you speak to the mindset
because i think what's actually powerful
is you have a background in digital
marketing and agencies and i think a lot
of people with that mindset are heavily
into paid traffic as they should be but
they think almost completely paid
traffic they don't think organic they
think direct response um and so
this is a it's kind of a different
approach the results are insane that you
guys have got but you're going organic
youtube traffic and a lot of the results
you got was with a relatively small
channel like under 5 000 subscribers
you're already starting to start getting
a lot of momentum sales and deal flow so
can you speak a little bit to the
mindset for the business owners like i
don't have time for youtube why would i
invest in youtube is this gonna be worth
it is it gonna be too much energy up
front why don't i just pay for leads
somewhere else why don't i just hire
zillow to send me leads that 85 of
people never follow up with anyway so i
don't know why they do it but yeah speak
to the mindset a little bit yeah i mean
it's you know you know for me the
mindset
was i was terrified of actually getting
on camera you know so so for me getting
on camera was the number one fear um
that i knew that i had to get over and
and my mindset was just one one step at
a time
break things down to the ridiculous you
know i can touch on you know paid
traffic and what like levi says this all
the time you know this this is something
that makes you time this doesn't take
you time and i think that he should
definitely talk about the amount of
watch hours that we've had we have
prospect with the amount of watch hours
we have prospect you know 10 15 years
into the future like if you imagine
making two hours you know it's making
cold calls for two hours a day or
following up with leads who don't know
who you are for two hours two hours a
day or three hours a day you will never
ever ever be able to keep up with us
because we are prospecting 24 7. we have
people in japan we have people in the uk
australia who are watching our channels
at what's three or four o'clock in the
morning our time but they're reaching
out to us and they're moving here who
else is prospecting
with your with your audience or your
database at 3am no one's doing that so
that in itself is extremely powerful but
i really want to talk about the the way
that i got over my fear of camera
because i do believe now after all my
years that youtube is the absolute best
way seo i believe is the best way
because when people find you they they
love you they really fall in love with
you and when you're doing relocation
they don't have 20 other agents locally
in dallas that that you're competing
against you know what i'm saying they
have to move in a very quick amount of
time they're selling their properties so
they actually have you know two or three
or four hundred thousand dollars in
equity so in the dallas market you know
we're doing seventy five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars over and someone
who is selling who has to move here
because they're tired of whatever it is
they're tired of or their job is
relocating over here it makes the
transaction really easy but the number
one thing that i did that i learned was
not everything has to be done in one
take right if you master your hook and
your intro the first two minutes of that
video and you're on fire and you're
you're doing you know every everything
is just perfect that is what i had the
hardest time because it was kind of
scripted right so
what i did was when when i saw levi's
basically his intro i wrote the intro
down i wrote our hook down i grabbed my
iphone and i just recorded myself you
know saying hey so you're thinking about
moving to dallas texas you know you do
your little hook well great you know i i
literally would listen to that in the
gym every single day when i was working
out and i was hitting the stairmaster or
something i would just listen over and
over and over and over again to my hook
in my intro so then a week later because
like it was so so funny because like the
first time i ever went out with levi we
were in mansfield and i know mansfield
really well but i did not know the very
beginning so i kept starting over and
over it just took a long a long time
when i mastered it it was like boom it
was just really natural because then i
in my head i compartmentalized this into
six steps right you have your hook you
have your intro you have three different
neighborhoods right so you have your
hook intro in three different
neighborhoods and then you have your
outro the the neighborhoods are really
easy those just need to take maybe two
or three minutes like it doesn't have to
take any certain amount of time maybe
it's five minutes maybe it's two minutes
like your video doesn't have to be 30
minutes long or an hour long it just it
needs to be what it is right whatever is
natural whatever flows that's what your
video needs to be so when i when i got
that down and i just said hey look okay
cool i'm going to the homes that are 350
to 450 i'm gonna i'm just gonna shoot
for two or three minutes so i'm just
like walking around my selfie stick you
know what i'm saying just
explaining everything that i see
and then whenever i started seeing these
like videos come out that were fully
edited i was like damn i'm good my
editor makes me look really really good
out here and so
that was the biggest thing for me was
with with the mindset is like you just
have to hit play you know what i mean
like do your work you know what i'm
saying like practice practice practice
and when you when you hit play you're
ready to go but you do need to put in
the work and you do want to practice but
when you when you get the first part i
believe when you're naturally whatever
it is your business is if you're really
good at your business you know it like
the back your hand like you may not
think that you can talk about it like i
didn't know what i was gonna say right
now but i know it so well now that it's
just it naturally just flows out so i
think when it comes to mindset you just
have to hit play whether that's
practicing in your your office
practicing outside just hit play and
break it down to the ridiculously easy
in your head and like when we're doing
office videos like really quick
there may be ten pros in and five cons
and this was like the office videos were
the hardest ones for me because there's
so much content that you that you had to
memorize and it's just so simple because
when your videos are edited and all put
together it just flows so i would maybe
say you know the first three pros right
and then i would kind of just step to
the side shake it off a little bit
i'd read my notes and i'd be like all
right cool those are the next three boom
hey all right so the third or the fourth
pro of living in dallas is xyz and so i
just step to the side take a little
breather get my get my mind right step
back in and then when it gets edited it
just looks amazing so just break it down
really simple but you have to get on
camera and you have to push play
well i want to highlight a tip you
shared and then uh follow up with some
questions man you're dropping some
serious fire smash light growth video
live show if you're getting value but
um one of my favorite things you said
when you want to learn some material is
record it in a voice memo on your phone
and then play it back and
i actually was talking to omar from the
think media team a lot of people don't
know he's actually a pastor at our
church as well and he was talking to our
lead pastor he's talking about how to
like kind of master parts of your sermon
and he said hey don't underestimate
recording what you want to say or even
writing it down recording you reading it
and then listening to it over and over
again and i the other day i was speaking
in florida and i really felt as i
learned about the audience that i wanted
to share a particular story that i'd
never really crafted before so i opened
up a notes app i wrote it out so i
probably took 30 minutes i had a couple
hours before i speak i took about 30
minutes to write it out well because we
can always write better than we could
you know to sit down think about what i
wanted to say then i just hit the voice
record memo and read off of it as best
as i could and then it took me like two
tries and i nailed it turned it off
because i also wanted to tell this story
concisely that was i think the huge key
like you said you wanted to master the
hook i wanted to tell this story
concisely i only had 40 minutes to speak
or something it's a little bit different
but the same idea with the youtube video
and then i just played it while i was
getting ready so i listened to it over
and over in the bathroom getting dressed
over sitting in the hotel room over and
over because again i had never
you know told this story crafted before
but it needed to be somewhat dialed by
the time i spoke in the afternoon here's
the big takeaway friends if you want to
master your hooks master your content
better record your own voice reading
something that's maybe polished and let
it just kind of get ingrained in you
such a cool
tip and and i also want to ask now
specifically as you've been raising up a
team because maybe other business owners
would want other people to get on camera
you have people in your office getting
on camera you we all are terrified to
get on getting on camera let us know in
the comments if you're also even still a
little camera shy or feeling like it's
tough to get on camera but i'm curious
levi like not only have you overcome
those hurdles travis is talking about
how he overcame fear and punch fear in
the face and press record
but now you have like people who maybe
never would have thought they'd be on
camera and you're creating a culture
of of creators that can
jump on and share why is moving to
california to dallas a good idea and
it's extending beyond you are you doing
any coaching mentoring how are you
helping your team get on camera
yeah so i mean we we have we built out a
full digital course on this to really
help uh not only our team but other real
estate agents all over the country even
all over the world i mean if they have
youtube in their country they can follow
our process and pattern that we've
developed and so it's it's a it is a
simple process to go through once you
understand everything but ultimately you
know they have to put in the work right
so we can sharpen people's sword but
they have to swing it and so therefore
it's just a matter of it does take
practice now for me
one thing that i had to really learn was
having a conversation with the camera
which you know
seeing my audience or the person i'm
trying to speak to really just if you
think about one person on the other side
of that camera that's who you're
speaking to so whoever your target
audience is whoever your avatar is and
you've probably heard that before may
sound a little cheesy but it's the
reality of it is that that's the people
that we speak to and that's what we
coach too as well especially with our
team is think about it a couple of those
team members that you've brought up have
called us watched our channel from
california worked with us to buy their
home and then they joined our team we
actually have four members on our team
that we've helped to relocate and they
loved
working with us so much so they were
fans but the experience was everything
that they thought it would be as well
that they wanted to join the team and so
you know now they that's one thing i
just help them help them understand is
just share your story your story your
experiences that's what youtube is
really all about you know and that's why
we're not worried about competition and
really even if there's 10 other agents
in your backyard on youtube that is not
competition trust me you know there's
going to be a hundred within the next
year or so so you might as well start
now but the reality is is that you know
every year hgtv uh doesn't uh you know
they come out with a new show a new real
estate show every single year why
because they know content is king and
everybody uh attracts to different
personalities and so therefore you know
ultimately i know youtube tells me the
top 15 channels that my audience watches
which is all real estate channels
especially in the dallas market but you
know we continually get calls every
single day because the people that call
us have already made the decision that
they want to work with us and so
therefore you know we don't feel like we
have competition because nobody calls us
to tell us hey we don't want to work
with you i mean you may get a funky
comment here or there but it doesn't
matter because ultimately
once that youtube takes if anybody's
familiar with a sales process a client
journey a sales funnel whatever it is
you want to call it to me youtube takes
them through that entire process
absolutely free and think about this
people search on their own people find
your channel on their own they watch
videos on their own and then youtube
actually does the youtube actually does
the work for you and recommends more and
more videos uh you know to for them to
watch and then they go move to the
bottom of the funnel when they call you
they have made that decision that they
want to work with you and so that's
another reason why our conversion rates
are so quickly and work so uh you know
so fast is because they they're in the
buying process they're in the research
mode and whenever they're calling us
they're ready to make a move
man i love it well i want to learn a
little bit more about specifically how
you built this up and
scaled into getting some editors on
board figuring out your process going
from just starting with your smartphone
because it can be a little overwhelming
so i want to reduce some overwhelm in
just a second um learn a little bit
about how you do time management in
regards to real estate and then also
being basically a content creator also
building up your personal brands um but
i want to ask a little bit you know i'm
excited you're coming out to grow a
video live as uh first of all you
registered you signed up i heard you
were coming and then i was like man we
got to have you guys as guest experts
and um i want to uh and so that means
there's going to be a couple different
guest experts at growth video live which
is just people you can have access to
particularly on the platinum day which
is the third mastermind day but i'm just
curious
why why would you want you're already
experiencing massive success too you
read youtube secrets and you're getting
results but you you wanted to invest in
yourself even more uh why is it
important for you to keep learning it
and what do you think is going to be um
powerful or growth video live
particularly that it stood out to you
well i mean we are sponges and that's
how we that's how we've grown so quickly
is because i i don't believe that i've
learned it all and i ever will learn it
all so i i believe wholeheartedly the
best education and investments is in
myself and so you know the thing is is
the reason that's one of the things
we've done most we we schedule out we
looked at in january all of the real
estate and video conferences for the
year and put those on the calendar first
and then we work our schedule around
those because i believe you know we go
to these conferences for the content for
the information but it's the
relationships that you leave with that
are the most important we're able to
network and meet people that we would
usually or probably never have excesses
access to in any other way you think
about it you know getting a chance to
speak with gary vee or alex hermosi you
know i registered for your event um and
travis and i because i know there's
value there regardless i registered with
no expectations at all whatsoever but
this is also because we've registered
for other events this has opened up
speaking opportunities or you know this
guest expert opportunity because we we
were already making the effort we've
already put in the money so what most
people make the mistake is they look at
today's cost versus tomorrow's value so
a conference may look like a lot of
money up front even if the tickets three
four five hundred dollars we paid for
the top level because i was like look
even though we have a relationship and
we've got to meet before i'm not going
to ask for anything i i i want to pay
the most because
i want to support you guys but at the
same time i also want to have the best
access because i want to open up these
other doors and these opportunities so
it's about being present it's about
moving forward it's about
going for the content and the
information but leaving with the
relationships and already this year
we've met some of the best people that
are helping us and want to further us
you know they they want to put us in
front of people they um you know we're
in talks with uh you know corporate
staff with uh you know other influencers
with other people that you know again we
would just never have the opportunity to
probably get in front of but people
become pretty accessible at some of
these events whether it's hanging out
at the beach you know or at the bar
afterwards or in between sessions or
after they speak
just those little moments can open up so
many opportunities and so we just
believe in in life on offense right
we're always going to move forward the
same reason why we we hired a real
estate coach you know for our team
because
everything has gone very smoothly for us
however we don't want to take that for
granted and for us it's a lot easier for
us to grow and move forward when we're
in a position of things going well
versus whenever things don't go wrong
and then our back is up against the wall
because if you ever work from
the defensive position or from
desperation you usually don't make the
best decisions and then you can usually
get in in a deeper hole so we're
constantly on offense
trying to you know learn grow and expand
and also uh you know jump over the
potholes versus drive through them which
is why we hire mentors coaches read
books go to conferences everything like
that because we want to make sure we
continue the success and and if we make
a mistake when things are going well
it's so much easier to recover and to
move forward and past it it doesn't it
doesn't you know blow a hole in your
business but if your back is against the
wall and and there's a mistake it could
be detrimental to your business so we're
just a life on offense uh type of people
so that's the reason but ultimately now
you know even registering for this event
when you you know presented this
opportunity it was i mean i couldn't
tell you how how excited we are about
that i mean and i believe it will be
life-changing and so you know we
appreciate that opportunity
but again we registered with no
expectation except for the opportunity
to learn and grow and continue to just
you know be students of the game is
really what it comes down to if you if
you think in that mindset
i think you'll always continue to to
grow and and you know tony robbins talks
about that right i mean growth is like
one of the most important things for
people to feel alive to feel like
they're progressing to feel like they're
moving forward it's it's usually when
people get stuck or they're not growing
or they're
regressing that you know things don't
don't work out or or tend to go as well
man i love it and man you said something
so powerful in there that uh too many
people think about today's cost and not
tomorrow's
value i mean when you make an investment
especially in real estate the real
estate mind understands this because uh
you invest in something today that is
going to appreciate even if actually it
goes down there's a little downturn in
the market you just know if i hang on to
this for five or ten years i'm still
gonna be okay because of the trend of
the market always appreciating it you're
trying to make smart investments and
that's what we hope that growth video
live is as well in fact we're confident
it's going to be that it's an investment
in your business your relationships your
network your knowledge and in just a
second travis and levi are going to
break down a few more tips um i really
want to learn about how they built a
team about how they scaled on youtube
because you only have so much time in a
day so how do you manage your time
but if you're only hearing about growth
video live now it's a live event
happening in las vegas or from the
comfort of your own home kick it on your
couch pop some popcorn grab a journal
and you can attend virtually as well and
so
we're going to get into some more tips
in just a second but of course the grow
with video live show is brought to you
by growth video live check out this
video do you want to get in the room
with experts like gary vaynerchuk
patrick vette david vanessa lau pat
flynn chalene johnson and more and would
you like to meet hundreds of other
creative entrepreneurs just like you
well then do not miss the chance to get
around creators and business influencers
at growth video live 2022 conference you
can actually lock in your limited
discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket
uh growthvideolive.com is the url and
because you are a part of the growth
video live show you can grab five
percent off any ticket level you know
the platinum ticket level which is the
third day
um is a pretty uh pretty uh pricey
ticket but um that's because uh it's a
much smaller group at a whole another
level of investment and um i would
you can use the code for that as well
and so the code is
gwvl show
um and uh excited for that um and so
growth video live is coming soon make
sure to grab your ticket if you've
grabbed your ticket let me know jason
says i'll be there virtually this is my
first one and i can't wait are you
already registered do you have any
questions are you on the fence there's
the code and caleb on the think teams on
facebook helping you with the uh code or
you can check out if you're watching
this on youtube live or on the replay
please check out the youtube description
for all of the details uh listen we're
gonna do the lightning round with travis
and levi
and if you have a question about growth
video live or a question about youtube
or growing your business
post it quick because we're gonna dive
into this stuff but here's my question
uh what have you guys done
um
what were the seasons
you started solo who was editing the
videos right up front maybe you hired in
the video editor right away how'd you
find them kind of lightning when did you
you know hire somebody how'd you get the
videos edited shot and then how what did
it grow into today
yeah so uh chrissy uh chrissy who is our
behind the scenes uh jack of jill i
should say jill of all trades i actually
found her on fiverr about three years
ago and
in my previous businesses she always did
contract work uh she's based in georgia
and i thought when i saw her prizes on
fiverr i thought uh first of all she
can't she can't be in this country
they're way too low but you know we
reached out and sure enough she was just
very affordable and especially for the
things that i was working on at the time
so she just did several things for me
but any time i asked her a question can
you do this she always said yes can you
do social media yes can you do you know
edit videos yes i can do that and so uh
she came on with us she's been with us
since the beginning of the start of the
channel even though we've been working
together so it was just a natural fit
but i understood from the very beginning
that i have zero skill in editing it's
not something that i want to do i love
how garyvee says you know you're not
lazy you're just not interested in what
you're doing well i have no interest in
editing either i and i also don't
believe as a real estate agent possibly
even a business owner it's probably not
the best use of your time unless that is
a very specific skill set that you want
to you know you know put into your
videos but i only know of one real
estate agent that edits his own videos
and he does a great job of doing that
but again that's not something i wanted
to take the time or effort to learn so i
instead of having a marketing budget we
did have an editing budget from the
beginning and so it was just a matter of
i just went out and shot with my iphone
i i understood watching other videos
that i could face the camera the other
way use the wide angle lens so that it
could capture a majority of the
background behind me because even though
i wanted i needed to be in the video to
build that brand i wanted the real
estate and everything behind me to be
seen as much as possible that wide-angle
lens on an iphone is absolutely amazing
again i still use an 11 pro i haven't
even upgraded it
at this point because it just works so
well and so she was able to do that and
as we started to scale and do more
business then it got to a point to where
our leads started coming in so so many
per day which right now we average about
seven inbound leads per day think about
that and so we moved her out of editing
found uh outsourced her editing uh with
the right person to take over that
because that was taking the majority of
her time and so we've just kind of
pieced everything together as we've
grown and that's what i really love
about youtube as well is youtube allows
you to grow and scale accordingly
because you're not going to
likely wake up to a million followers
the next day it's going to grow very
slowly and you know like travis
mentioned we closed our first two homes
in april of last year in uh in march we
closed three homes well march last month
we we closed 35 homes in one month so
you see that progression but the thing
is is that it went from two to three to
five to seven to nine to eleven and so
that progression over last year allowed
us to scale accordingly because the the
channel grew up you know uh at with
organically we'd never run a single ad
to it and just worked on the back end
seo and optimization to get found in
search results and then in november
finally after almost a year we had a
couple of videos that you could say went
mini viral and i say many viral i mean
one went to 40 000 views inside of one
month and that was the most we've ever
seen we've always just had steady eddie
growth on
on each video they were all pretty much
about the same but and again last year
we averaged two leads per day and since
january we averaged seven leads per day
which is uh you know gone from the
growth that's the compound effect that's
the power of video that's the power of
youtube you know like travis mentioned
earlier last year our channel was
watched 66
600 watch hours well if you divide that
by 24 hours in a day that's equivalent
to 7.6 years so that means our channel
prospected 7.6 years in a one-year time
frame that is compounding time and so
now this year our channel is almost
prospecting a year per month so at the
end of this year we're projecting to
have 12 to 14 years of watch time inside
of one year so that's the amount of
growth that can compound but now we have
the systems and people in place that we
can scale that accordingly and how we
brought on the team was we held a live
event you know we held a live event in
december of last year uh you know to
talk about what we were doing on youtube
and we were looking to grow and we had
about 75 people and about five people
from the 75 said we want to be on your
team we want to join you and then we got
the other four from people that we
helped transition from california that
wanted to uh you know so all that
happened quickly but we had the systems
in place to do that and everything we
built out like travis mentioned earlier
the automations the triggers um the you
know the processes for the client
journey whenever they reach out to us
all of that was pieced together piece by
piece every time something didn't work
or broke i would say okay we need an
automation for that we need a trigger
for that we need a campaign for that you
know if you have to do anything twice in
your business you should develop a
process or an sop or an automation or a
trigger or a campaign or something like
that and so you know i don't teach
people youtube our course teaches people
youtube now or at least real estate
agents you know and so even when people
come on our team they get the course you
know it's it's a training ground for our
own team as well as well as people all
over the country but i always say look
you can we can schedule a call after you
go through that course because now i
have something that is duplicatable it's
scalable it doesn't take me i don't have
to explain youtube to them 100 by the
time we get on a call they have one or
two questions because 99 of their
questions have been answered through
that and so it's all about
creating that you know those types of
systems because whatever you do and if
you would believe this sean i bet you
would is that making videos is the least
amount of time i spend uh during my work
week now because it's such a
systematized even for myself it is
second nature now if i make a 15 minute
video it takes me 15 minutes to make
that video because it is just it's a
part of me now and so it is the true
four hour work week if you've ever read
that book video is the true four hour
work week i don't know what else you can
do to where actually i don't even make
four hours worth of videos per week i
make about one to two possibly total in
a one week time frame and that is
prospecting for us compounding our
return compounding our time there's no
other way anytime you invest in
something your number one question is
usually and that's whether you're buying
real estate stocks crypto bitcoin
whatever it is your number one question
is probably is what's going to be the
return on my investment well if you're
going to invest your time into something
like social media you should ask
yourself what's going to be the return
on my time and so youtube that's what i
love about it is all the back-end
analytics tell you exactly what you're
getting in return for that so if you
if a video takes you 30 minutes to make
as soon as that video's watched 31
minutes you've profited one minute of
your time so that makes it worth it to
spend that 30 minutes making that video
because you just profited one minute of
your time but i'll tell you that it when
it returns hours and days and years it
nothing else can match that
man you dropped on some serious fire
this is a episode of rewatch the amount
of information that travis and levi
dropped was very dense and so it's very
good to
uh check out the replay of this as well
and actually if you know an agent
specifically somebody in real estate
share this video with them you know tag
them or share this or forward it to them
because we want to get the power of
youtube into people's hands like the
results speak for themselves and
ultimately not only can we get
impact people specifically with selling
their home buying their home right but
also the income that can
impact your family your lifestyle and
really help you scale your real estate
business so if you know an agent tag
them share them email this to them dm it
to them uh tick tock dm that's i don't
think that i don't think that's a thing
but um
and also if you want to connect more
with levi and travis not just at the
entire event but as guest experts on the
uh on the platinum day that's our
business mastermind day it's a higher
level it's not cheap but if that sounds
right for you you can go to
gwvlplatinum.com links are in the
description down below all the details
are there uh travis how can people
connect with you uh online and uh follow
you and what you're doing
yeah i mean the best place to follow me
is on instagram first name last name
travis plum like a plumber without the
er
i love it and then uh levi uh where can
people check out all your stuff
yeah instagram as well if you're a real
estate agent i post a lot of content on
there about youtube so at levi lassic if
you type in levi l it'll probably pop up
i have a little orange background on my
profile pic but you'll you'll find it on
there and we do have another youtube
channel that's agent facing which is
called the real agents and that's
r-e-e-l so the real agents you can
search that on youtube and that's a real
estate agent facing channel the reason
we separate the two is because they're
two completely different audiences and
that's one thing as a real estate agent
if you put real estate agent facing
content on your channel then you run the
risk of losing the opportunity to work
with real estate clients so if you're if
you want to attract both in some form or
fashion we recommend two different
channels it's two different audiences
and therefore now that's twice the work
but at the same time it'll it'll pay you
back much greater than just trying to
put it all on one channel
beautiful levi travis thank you so much
for adding so much value today if you
got value out of the growth video live
show today can you hit the like button
and share your aha moment remember we
are action takers at think media and so
what are you gonna do next uh you may be
early in your journey maybe midway you
may be ready to scale what's an action
item for you are you ready to post that
next video are you ready to actually
maybe get your back in fixed up like
travis does because again it's one thing
to get traffic and even leads a lot of
times creators mismanage honestly and
mishandle their follow-up process the
fortunes in the follow-up you want to
make sure your systems your funnels your
email your calling you want to make sure
all that stuff is dialed if you
specifically want to learn more of this
business level thinking then uh join us
for the platinum day at grow up video
live but remember grow a video live show
uh is brought to you by growth video
live we're just a few weeks away in
person gary vaynerchuk online
patrickbetdavid it's a it's an
interactive experience no matter what
level you join us at it's going to be
incredible and because you're a part of
the show we'll hook you up with five
percent off but make sure to get your
ticket quick because in just a few days
early bird pricing is ending all the
tickets are going up a couple hundred
dollars and so now is definitely the
time to grab your ticket before early
bird pricing ends uh and i want to thank
you again for being a part of the grow
with video live show and we will see you
soon on the next episode this thing is
your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is than put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room he
will sit back in 20 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute in this era it has
never been a better time in the human
race ever to actually just go all in on
you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i